Mike and I were at a conference a while
ago and the person before I started a
video and then didn't say anything in 10
minutes into the video half the audience
got up and walked out and the rest of
the audience was talking among
themselves which just goes to prove what
most this conference has been saying in
the wonderful presentation before us
it's not the video but what you do with
it and that's really what we're going to
talk about right now not going to press
the button for me you want me to yeah
anyways I'm Dean ray Viger this is mike
fagan we're from matrix where humanities
computing center and social science
center extra and social sciences now we
have moved over at Michigan State
University we do lots of different kinds
of things for the most part we've been
focusing on developing digital libraries
we got lots of stuff online we got some
real nifty stuff coming up we put on
about eight hundred dollars of studs
terkel audio we have a lot of video
coming up we did the American black
Journal which started in nineteen sixty
eight as the colored people's time with
the Detroit Public Television we're
putting all the interviews on since
nineteen sixty eight we have about 60 a
month up online now and they go from
desmond tutu Jesse Jackson to Bobby
Seale some really interesting interviews
and we have a real nice oral history
collection that focuses on the fight
against apartheid in South Africa as
well as many other collections but we
did that for a long time and then we
found out something tragic is that
students aren't really using digital
libraries very much and they're not
using very successful especially the
media the audio and the video and
teachers would use it very much so
that's really what we've been focused on
lately is how can we be more effective
in the use of the media because we
really like everyone here believe in
access and we want to give people
but access as i said the beginning
really doesn't come without the ability
to use it and reuse it in new and
different ways the obstacles of course
are our pre familiar to all of you for
the most part people have real difficult
time searching a lot of the digital
library interfaces are just terrible
american memory is just a nightmare if
you want to try to use it so what we're
really focused on is development
secondary posit or ease as people use
the materials you're going to gather a
metadata by by the very use user
generated metadata and the other
obstacle of course is how do you deal
with the streaming media we know how to
deal with text we have a deal with text
for a long time academics are really
good at quoting things and things like
that and so we really kind of built a
tool that very much follows on the tool
that you just saw a waste for people to
create annotations and segments out of
larger screens that are online and then
use them we're archive and website
independent you can use it anywhere as I
said you can sign up for an account now
and start using it and you can use them
just about any site you want matter of
fact one of the things we really
encourage with students is to use it for
their own personal stuff we know that if
students use application for personal
use they'll come to use for academic use
more you do not want to see what they
collected in terms of media for personal
use but that's another story anyways
with that my tears slide yet oh yeah we
do yours like Mike will go now did you
do is criticize Library of Congress I
criticized what we don't to dismiss
myself for me um no no there's wonderful
place and you love them like or Congress
is great but we're just going to use a
specific cause right yes so to enable
you to better use online video we
created an application called media
matrix and as dean said Media Metrix
allows you to segment and annotate live
media that you find online it's an
archived independent tool which means
you can use it with virtually all media
that you find on a website you can
organize your media on a personal
workspace and then you can combine that
media
into online presentations so I think the
best way to take a look at this is to
actually run through a demo oh good i'm
logged in so me matrix is free to use
all you have to do is create an account
and once you create an account you can
go to your portal page and there's two
ways to load the media matrix tools one
is through a series of bookmarks which
simply appear in your bookmark folder
the other way is an installer and media
matrix is fully supported on firefox on
both platforms in internet explorer and
what that does is it adds options to
your contextual menu ok so once you
actually install the tools you're ready
to head out onto the internet and start
gathering stuff and annotating and so
let's start small and let's grab an
image so once you come to a website and
find an object that you want you deploy
the appropriate media matrix tool and so
you can do one of two things you can
click on the page and say I want to find
an image on this page and what this does
is it goes through it parses to the page
and generates a preview and finds the
images so that you can select one to
load into the media matrix editor but as
a page like this it's got a ton of stuff
on it so you can also just right click
on an object and just go to add to media
matrix and what this does is it loads
the object into the editor and once the
objects into the editor you can work
with it and so with images you can
increase and decrease the size of it and
you can also segment it for images that
just means creating a virtual crop and
so I drew this box around a portion of
the image and I can preview it and so
that generates on the fly a preview of
the crop and then once you have the
digital object modified you can again
give it a title
it's always the toughest thing to come
up with the title and add your
annotation and what you can do is you
can organize your stuff in the folders
and if you one of the options is we have
a citation layer we quickly look at that
the citation layer what before you go to
a citation layer you can add additional
metadata to any object so you can create
metadata skins to describe objects that
make sense to you and so I just have an
example here if I wanted to I could
apply some dublin core fields to the
actual information that I'm stayed
storing for this object but once you've
actually finished the object it takes
you to the citation layer what the
citation layer is it's a series of
questions to get undergrads to think
about why they're collecting this
resource and how they're going to use it
in their paper yeah I'm in fact one of
the main things that we developed a tool
for was research to find out how people
actually use and think about resources
they find that in line and that's been
our primary primary mission so once
you've collected your resource and on a
bad student ID info local citation layer
you can go to your tree and on your tree
it has all the things that you collect
so if we open this up it again it
generates a preview and what it does is
it again rights where digital archive
copyright is very important let me say
before you get out the clubs and the
pitchforks and torches where we're not
actually downloading any of the media
that we use with me d matrix it simply
stores a URL back to the object and the
parameters for segmenting it and so
basically it's a big text database the
digital media stays on the server that
is located on and we simply access it
when the user accesses it where it sits
a lot of bloggers actually use this
because what you can do
HTML that you can just place your blog
and get the same kind of crappie are the
same kind of segmentation of the video
as well so um once it's on your mediator
you can again you can load it back into
the editor you can revise it and you
know the other options you usually have
in a workspace you can edit them you can
move around into folders that type of
thing ok so our director says we have to
be more of a corporate shill so for
audio and video game mention the
American black Journal it's going to be
a fine sight we're going to be releasing
about two weeks we're just doing some
finishing on it and we have the rights
to use everything to we don't have the
rights to check public television pass
through toy coked-up you just simply put
that's a good question we do it well you
talk about the link checker when you
access your tree it basically goes
through and checks each link if the link
is broken it notifies you that this link
is broken we also store the network the
URL to the object the URL you've got the
page got the object from the page and so
you can go back to the page where you
found it in sort of search around but if
you also try to strongly suggest
archives and stable you our eyes and we
try to promote that and everything we do
what's the loyalty so this is the
American black journal and for video
again you can go to a page that has a
video clip and you can see
this is streaming a 28-minute clip all I
think all the shows were half hour
approximately in length unless a big
promise teacher simply can't use a half
hours in our show and students don't
want to use that for the paper you can
interrupt so I'm as the video streaming
what you can do is you can again go to
find video it automatically locates the
video on the page and loads it into the
editor um if there's so as this is
streaming what you can do is you can
again hit start segment and end segment
and with our new version it's really
cool be a little slider to make quite
easy be done yes um so oh yeah we was
thrown a little skip when you are when
you hit start segment and n segments
what you can do is you can preview the
actual segment and here you can see
instead of the 28th minute clip what it
does it just plays the three seconds
that I recorded so again we're not
actually downloading or making a
derivative copy of the digital object or
simply storing those two parameters as
well as the URI back to the video which
is really cool because one of the things
we do we have another application that
were released an open source called
project builder with is a repository
software and it allows us actually to
just instead of creating lots of
derivatives
things we can actually just have our
experts actually create segments for us
put them into the database we store them
as objects that we can use for web
presentations this is especially really
important when you have by overcoming
apartheid site dealing with South
African history and so we can have
scholars from all over the world log
into the digital repository and build
context around these actually create the
clips as well as the context of arming
clips without having to have any
technical knowledge whatsoever you get
two minutes oh okay so video file no and
let's go to my portal so you go from
site to site and collect the digital
media that you want segment and annotate
and what you can do is you create a
presentation of the things you collect
and so this is not unlike a word
processor you can type in some words I
can't beat it with time constraint one
minute so um any place in the actual
presentation what you can do is you can
hit one of these and add appropriate it
goes to your tree and finds everything
that you've collected and you can select
what you want to insert and you can add
it to a presentation so it's just add
our video we only have one there
video clip okay so once you're done you
can go ahead and hit you can if you're
part of a group you can create groups
for classes you can hand things in
directly to your instructor who's the
administrator of the group but we're
just going to add it and what this
creates is a a web page with a again a
solid URL and embed your stuff and you
can again click on your stuff and it
will recreate the segment you can see
this is going to play the three seconds
it also displays the citation
information for the student and so the
instructors really like it because you
know when they get a research paper D&I
both teach humanities you know you only
have the quote there if you want to
check the co and gotta go look up the
book and things like this here an
instructor can see what the student was
thinking when they actually collected
the resource they can actually view the
clip as well as go back to the site and
see what site they got it from and if it
using it what's in the right context you
can also collect audio focus your
attention on page 50 texts page
we're currently as I said we're
currently going open source with one of
our project this summer and then the
next one we're going to try to go open
source with this one it just takes time
for us to you know make a package for
people to download but yes we want to
make it free and open for education with
you so they said you can use it off our
server right now any time there's lots
of people with people at Texas State
University actually you see for teacher
education where they have long videos of
teacher teaching in classroom and the
teachers can pick up segments that work
and don't work we have being used at
Tufts University and several other
places actually around the world so
you're in place and what measures are
things yeah right now it's a story time
it's really scalable and for us it's the
University bureaucracy of getting the
okayed as you release it so we're hoping
soon
no they can actually type textual quotes
in right yeah just like it right here
yeah yeah yeah yeah well we have a hole
that we have some of the presentation
layers we're building you know the whole
thing that we're dealing with is the
fact that there's lots of editors out
there you have the video and it becoming
easier and easier you can edit it but
there's very few things that actually
deal with the things that come out of
digital libraries are streaming online
but there's more and more that content
available for use and that's what we're
trying to work with so we support the
big three wav mp3 and mpeg-4 we're
almost to flash I would say within a
month we're gonna have flash we can work
with flash on our server it's more
difficult to work with flash it's
located on other servers but we've had
successful tests but the flash player
slightly changed so we want to make sure
we're compatible with all players again
this is being used for a number of
different instances it's nice that our
director is also the chair of history so
we get lots of classrooms to work in as
well as all their virtual courses are
using it as well again we're interested
as a repository with secondary
repositories and what that is is a big
pot of user-generated matter where
they're commenting and creating context
on digital objects that are located
elsewhere and so oh this not only
provides finding aids but I'm talking
really quick okay I find it online it's
really exciting try it out there's a
video he made he stars and then you can
actually
Santa I didn't appear at all that was by
design thank you